I understand you to say there's even more genetic info than we received in the 200 page report.
So, depending on when you received your genetic report from us, it was different pages. When I
started doing the genetic report, it was only like 35 pages. And then we were very proud that it was
a 60 page report. Well, that was over 380 pages that are reported. Yeah, but there's a whole bunch of
other genes that, you know, haven't really, they're not, you know, that nobody's looking at
unless you're a cancer doctor like me. So, I'm the only one to eat DNA supplementations report that's
looking at tumor presser genes or oncogene. So, I have to search for those. So, they're not
common genes that one would look for. And then there's a ton of other genes that there's really
very little to no research on. So, it doesn't pay to put them in the report because we don't know
what they mean yet. So, there's as data comes out on what these different gene families do,
then that report has been expanded. And now it's expanded at 380 pages. So, and I can access to it.
Well, I'll have to pull yours up and download and see how many pages come up. When we did different
people's genes throughout the years, they may have tested for less. I don't know. So, I have to look.